[Música]
Hola Esto es África siete días el
magazine donde les presentamos la
actualidad del continente africano Mi
nombre es amal benotman Y estos son los
titulares
11,3% es la tasa de la bajísima
participación en la segunda vuelta de
las elecciones legislativas de túneles
prueba para muchos que los electores y
ya no confían en su clase política
mientras el país se de golpeado por una
crisis económica la oposición ha pedido
la salida del presidente
en la República democrática del Congo el
papa realiza una visita oficial de
cuatro días pero en este país de 96
millones de habitantes donde el 40% de
la población es católica la iglesia
romana compite cada vez más con las
evangélicas
los nigerianos se preparan para las
próximas elecciones generales previstas
para el 25 de febrero y los jóvenes que
representan más del 80% de los nuevos
inscritos en las listas electorales
esperan un cambio radical y pretenden
hacerse oír en estos comicios
[Música]
abrimos esta emisión en túnez donde la
principal coalición opositora llamó a
crear un frente unido para destituir al
jefe de estado caest esto se produjo
tras la segunda vuelta de las elecciones
parlamentarias marcadas por una
abstencionismo que no se registraba
desde el derrocamiento en 2011 de la
dictadura desde Lali es de bajo nivel de
participación es ampliamente considerado
por muchos como un repudio al presidente
acusado por sus detractores de ser
incapaz de sacar al país de la crisis
que enfrenta la principal preocupación
de los tunecinos es la economía pues han
visto su poder adquisitivo caer en
picada con una inflación superior al 10%
colegios electorales casi vacíos y una
abstención récord desde la revuelta
Popular de 2011 que provocó la caída de
la dictadura en túnez para la segunda
vuelta de las elecciones legislativas
solo el 11,3% de las personas en edad de
votar acudieron a las urnas aunque los
pocos ciudadanos presentes en este
colegio electoral de túnez no quieren
perder la esperanza
necesitamos cambios en todas partes
necesitamos cambios positivos para
mejorar Ese es el interés de los
ciudadanos debemos trabajar por el
futuro del país para desarrollarnos tras
el cierre de las urnas la oposición
aprovechó este índice de abstención para
pedir un frente político y sindical
Unido el objetivo expulsar al presidente
caíste y organizar unas elecciones
presidenciales anticipadas
pido a todos los que forman parte del
Movimiento Político y a los que están en
el movimiento civil que estén a la
altura del nuevo reto que tenemos ante
nosotros trabajemos codo a codo para
crear un cambio con la salida de caíste
pero el problema es mucho más profundo
en este país del norte de África muchos
tunecinos han perdido totalmente la
confianza en la clase política y han
decidido dejar de votar desilusionados
por una crisis económica que solo se
agrava
ya no voto soy pobre y he votado muchas
veces en el pasado para conseguir un
cambio pero al final no se ha conseguido
nada
estas elecciones legislativas pretendían
renovar 131 de los 161 diputados y
representa un paso más en la
hiperpresidencialización del sistema
político tunecino en julio de 2021
se hizo con casi todos los poderes
disolvió el parlamento y cambió la
constitución
cambiamos de tema y nos vamos a la
República democrática del Congo donde el
Papa Francisco realiza una visita
oficial de cuatro días se trata del
primer viaje de un pontífice al país
desde el que realizó Juan Pablo II en
1985 para los católicos congoeleños se
trata de un acontecimiento muy
importante pero en este país del centro
de África la Iglesia Católica se ve cada
vez más desafiada por las evangélicas
veamos
organizador de eventos en la República
democrática del Congo nació de padres
católicos y se identifica como tal pero
como cada vez más personas en el país
malela es también miembro de una iglesia
evangélica
prefiero las iglesias evangélicas porque
las soluciones son milagrosas son
soluciones que ni siquiera seríamos
capaces de explicar a veces tienes un
problema de salud o un problema en tu
matrimonio y vas a los hospitales a
buscar soluciones de forma científica
pero no las encuentras
la rdc alberga la mayor comunidad
Católica Romana de África que representa
alrededor del 40% de los 96 millones de
habitantes pero en este país del centro
de África el movimiento evangélico cobró
fuerza en la década de 1990 bajo la
presidencia del dictador mobutu cc seco
que quería contrarrestar las voces
católicas críticas de su régimen el
movimiento evangélico cuenta ahora con
más de 30.000 Iglesias en todo el
territorio se las conoce también como
por las iglesias revivalistas en
realidad la popularidad de la iglesia
revivalista no es nueva Los Seguidores
han entendido que el espíritu de Dios ha
estado trabajando con estas Iglesias los
fieles la aprecian porque encuentran la
verdad encuentran curas y a veces el
espíritu santo les habla de una manera u
otra y es lo que buscan según algunos
sociólogos la prolongada crisis social y
política del país explica esta
propagación de las iglesias evangélicas
mientras malella sigue haciendo sus
confidencias tanto al pastor de su
iglesia evangélica como a su sacerdote
católico para él no hay contradicciones
en ser miembro de ambas Iglesias explica
que la evangélica le da respuestas
concretas a sus problemas mientras que
la Católica le confiere un fuerte
sentido de comunidad en eso la última
monarquía absoluta de África el abogado
y defensor de los Derechos Humanos tú la
anima seco fue asesinado en su domicilio
el sábado 21 de enero Era uno de los
pilares del levantamiento que hace dos
años en este pequeño reino ubicado entre
Sudáfrica y mozambique en junio de 2021
por primera vez en la historia del país
miles de manifestantes pidieron reformas
democráticas y tú la animaseco ayudó a
unificar el movimiento y a coordinar las
protestas horas antes de su asesinato El
rey de swattini en tercero había
amenazado a sus oponentes en tercero es
a menudo criticado pero rara vez
directamente desafiado una de las
principales denuncias en su contra tiene
que ver con su extravagante estilo de
vida en uno de los países más pobres del
mundo
otro país otro asesinato Aparentemente
motivado políticamente Martínez Soho
tenía 51 años y era director de la radio
privada
la capital de Camerún su cuerpo mutilado
y en descomposición fue encontrado el 22
de enero el comunicador presentaba un
programa Popular en el que debatía
asuntos de corrupción y no dudaba en
desafiar a figuras políticas y
empresariales el sindicato nacional de
periodistas de Cameron expresó su
consternación escuchemos a uno de los
colegas de Soho
el mensaje que se está enviando con la
barbaridad del asesinato de Martínez
Soho es un mensaje de miedo que quieren
instalar en los periodistas y en todos
aquellos que decidieron no callarse ante
el fraude que se está produciendo en
este país
la ong internacional
ha pedido a las
llevar a cabo una investigación
independiente sobre el asesinato
Camerún es gobernado desde hace más de
40 años por el mismo hombre Paul y no es
la primera vez que agreden a periodistas
en este país del centro de África el 9
de marzo de 2022 se reportero por
secuestrado y violentamente agredido
antes de ser arrojado a una carretera en
agosto de 2019 otro periodista Samuel
murió detenido 10 meses después de ser
arrestado
continuamos nuestro repaso por la
actualidad africana con las próximas
elecciones en Nigeria el 25 de febrero
los nigerianos elegirán a su nuevo
presidente la participación suele ser
baja en el país pero este año los
votantes Especialmente los jóvenes se
apresuraron para inscribirse y obtener
sus tarjetas de votante en la comisión
electoral
conseguir una tarjeta de votante en
Nigeria similar a una carrera de
obstáculos Hay que llegar al amanecer y
hacer fila durante horas pero esto no
parece desanimar a los jóvenes
nigerianos determinados hacer oír su voz
en las elecciones del 25 de febrero y
que sueñan con un cambio
en 2019 no sentía que la necesidad de
cambio era tan grande pero hoy está muy
muy claro es hora de hacer la transición
y dar el poder a una nueva generación
en las urnas se definirá Quién será el
sucesor de muamaru y de 80 años quien
permanece en el poder desde 2015
se retira tras dos mandatos como lo
establece la Constitución unos 10
millones de nuevos votantes están
inscritos la mayoría de ellos El 84%
tiene menos de 34 años
Estoy muy emocionada de ejercer mi
derecho al voto por primera vez de votar
a las personas adecuadas en el gobierno
para hacer de Nigeria un país grande y
orgulloso
nigerios del país más poblado de África
y cuenta con 93 millones de votantes
expedirles tarjetas no es una tarea
fácil para los funcionarios de la
comisión electoral las pasadas
elecciones se han visto empañadas por
retrasos logísticos violencia y
acusaciones de fraude pero la comisión
electoral afirma que las elecciones de
2023 serán más transparentes gracias a
la identificación biométrica y la
transferencia electrónica de resultados
además de la recogida de tarjetas la
participación estará condicionada por la
posibilidad de acudir a las urnas gran
parte del territorio nigeriano está a su
lado por una grave inseguridad por la
insurgencia yihadista en el noreste Ban
que causan estragos en el Noroeste y
disturbios separatistas en el sureste
ante esto el gobierno dice que se han
puesto en marcha algunas medidas ver
basificada a la nación es una de las
mayores expectativas de los votantes que
también quieren un presidente capaz de
reparar la economía casi uno de cada dos
nigerianos vive en la pobreza extrema y
no percibe los beneficios que trae el
petróleo en un país que es uno de sus
mayores productores
los principales candidatos a las
elecciones presidenciales son tres bola
chinobu tiene 70 años y fue gobernador
del estado del lagos se beneficiará del
apoyo del partido gobernante El Congreso
de todos los progresistas
tiene 76 años Fue vicepresidente y es un
importante Hombre de negocios que
presenta su sexta candidatura
presidencial representa a la principal
formación opositora el partido
democrático de los pueblos y finalmente
el candidato Peter Ovi tiene 61 años
exgobernador y miembro del partido
laborista es el outsider que promete
llevar a cabo el cambio tan añado
mujeres y hombres de la tercera edad en
las pasarelas de los últimos grandes
desfiles de moda estas imágenes
hiperrealistas fueron creadas con
Inteligencia artificial por el artista
nigeriano Malik afecbúa él también
cineasta dio la oportunidad de desafiar
lo que ve como la marginación de las
personas mayores africanas en la
sociedad y las percepciones sobre el
envejecimiento en el mundo de la moda
los dejamos con las imágenes de sus
creaciones gracias por su sintonía la
actualidad sigue en France 24 y France
24.com
[Música]